- In the world of language nerdery,
there's perhaps no greater language nerd
than the conlang language nerd.
Conlang is short for constructed language,
and it refers to languages
that don't evolve
from the organic forces
of culture, but rather,
were deliberately designed
by one or more individuals.
Conlangers spend years, decades,
even lifetimes building their languages.
And let me tell you,
there is a lot more to it
than just making up a few
or a few thousand words.
According to "The
Language Construction Kit"
by Mark Rosenfelder, you
have to decide on phonetics,
morphology, orthography, syntax,
and semantics, just for starters.
It also helps to be familiar
with lots of existing languages.
If English is your only
frame of reference,
you'll be missing out
on the wonderful variety
of sounds and systems that
humans have generated.
Will your language be
agglutinative like Turkish?
Will it have subject-object-verb
structure like Japanese?
Or maybe ergative-absolutive
alignment like Basque?
I told you this was gonna get nerdy.
It may not seem like there's
much practical application
for conlangs in the real world,
but the history of invented languages
deepens our understanding
of language in general,
its potential, its
limitations, and its beauty.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky,
and this is Otherwords.
(whimsical music)
♪ Otherwords ♪
Perhaps the most famous
conlanger is J.R.R. Tolkien,
linguist and author of
"The Lord of the Rings."
Creating his fictional elvish languages,
Quenya and Sindarin,
was Tolkien's true passion and priority.
(speaking in Sindarin)
(speaking in Quenya)
He was inspired by the
beauty of Finnish and Welsh,
and because real languages
evolved with time,
Tolkien wanted his too as well.
This required writing a
detailed history and mythology
of the people who spoke
them, which ended up becoming
one of the most beloved
fiction franchises of all time,
and basically, created an entire genre
of popular entertainment.
This is more or less the opposite
of how that other super nerdy
fictional language came about.
In the early 1980s, a linguist
named Marc Okrand was hired
by Paramount Pictures to
devise a Klingon language
for the upcoming third film
in the Star Trek franchise.
Up to that point, the only
Klingon that had ever been heard
were a few lines actor
James Doohan came up with
while filming "Star Trek,
The Motion Picture."
(speaking in Klingon)
Okrand figured that since
this was an alien race,
he ought to choose features
that are very rare in human languages,
like an odd object-verb-subject
sentence structure
and a collection of phonemes
that are difficult to
pronounce individually,
let alone in quick succession.
(speaking in Klingon)
Okay.
Okrand also wanted the language
to match the coarse war-like culture
of the people who speak it.
So Klingon has many different
synonyms for fighting,
but no word for hello.
The closest you can get
is, (speaks in Klingon)
which means, what do you want?
Linguist David J. Peterson
took a similar tack
when inventing Dothraki for
the "Game of Thrones" TV show.
It has 14 different ways to say horse,
but none for thank you.
When helping James Cameron
develop the Na'vi language for "Avatar,"
linguist Paul Frommer wanted it
to be relatively easy for
the actors to pronounce.
Though he did include
some ejective phonemes,
voiceless consonants produced
with a contracted glottis,
like ch'ah and p'ah,
similar to those found
in real-world languages
like Mayan and Chechen.
Na'vi does not require specifying
gender in its pronouns,
though it does offer two forms of we.
We as in me and you, and we
as in me and someone else.
That way you always know exactly
who's invited to the sa'eoio.
Clearly, it takes a lot of work
to make a fictional language sound real.
But does anyone actually
speak them? Not really.
Of all the fictional languages,
Klingon has the greatest number
of truly conversant speakers
and they can probably
all fit onto one bus.
Fictional languages like Klingon, Quenya,
and Na'vi were invented mainly
for artistic and aesthetic purposes.
However, some language inventors
were much more ambitious.
They believed their
creations were actually
improvements over natural languages,
that they could unlock human
potential and better the world.
In the 17th century, many
scholars became preoccupied
with the Tower of Babel problem.
According to the Bible,
God cursed humanity with
many different languages
as punishment for building
a really tall tower.
The inability to communicate,
these scholars believed,
was still holding civilization back,
and they thought they could fix it
by trying to outdo God once again
with a man-made universal language.
The most famous attempt of the time
was by Bishop John
Wilkins, who didn't like
that words were just
arbitrary representations
that had to be memorized.
He believed that in a
perfect universal language,
the very essence of a concept
should be encoded into the word itself,
with each letter representing
a hierarchy of classifications.
For example, a dog was called zita
because it was a domesticated,
land-dwelling carnivore
with an oblong head and claws.
This barely makes sense
when describing animals,
but Wilkins tried to classify everything,
and I mean everything!
The result is hundreds and hundreds
of pages of complex hierarchies,
many of which are pretty subjective.
For example, witchcraft is categorized
under Judicial Relations,
subheading Capital Crimes.
As we explained in a previous video,
what Wilkins didn't
understand, is that words
being arbitrary memorizations
is not a bug, it's a feature.
It allows us to share a
vast mental dictionary
that can be effortlessly
and instantly accessed.
We don't need to describe
a dog every time we say it
because we all already
agree on what a dog is.
Despite the failure of
Wilkin's life's work,
the dream of a universal
language was resurrected
in the late 19th century when a small book
called "Lingvo Internacia"
was self-published
by someone calling himself Dr. Esperanto,
which means one who hopes.
It was a guidebook for an
international auxiliary language,
a kind of backup language,
which could be used by people
from different nations to
communicate with each other.
The true author was L.L. Zamenhof,
a Jewish ophthalmologist
and amateur linguist
who grew up in a diverse area of Poland.
Like Wilkins, Zamenhof believed
that a universal auxlang
could benefit the human race.
But unlike Wilkins, he wanted
it to be easy to learn,
so he borrowed familiar morphemes
from existing Indo-European languages,
like hom- for man, and am- for love,
and a very simple, predictable grammar.
Anyone with a couple of years
of Spanish under their
belt should be capable
of decoding simple sentences,
like kio estas via nomo?
Today, Esperanto is the biggest
real-world success story
of all invented languages.
There are hundreds of
thousands of fluent speakers,
including several thousand raised on it.
However, it never quite became
a universal auxiliary language,
perhaps due to the rise
in power of Britain
and the United States after World War II,
which cemented English's role
as a de facto lingua franca.
But international diplomacy
isn't the only problem
that conlangers have tried to fix.
In the early 20th century,
a linguist named Benjamin
Whorf hypothesized
that the language you speak
limits your perceptions and cognition,
like maybe having more words for colors
would actually enable
you to see more colors,
and maybe Klingons would be nicer
if they did have a word for hello.
Some even worried that humanity's reliance
on language prevented us
from understanding the true
nature of the universe.
Words might be Plato's
shadows on the cave wall.
Sociologist James Cooke Brown wanted
to test the Whorf hypothesis
by inventing a language that
could empower its speakers
to shed all their preconceptions
and think with perfect logic.
Loglan, short for logical language,
is an example of an engineered language,
one designed for theoretical
or experimental purposes.
Its grammar was based
on first order logic,
the kind used in mathematics
and computer science,
which makes literal translations sound
more like equations than sentences.
Loglan was designed to
be totally unambiguous,
there can only be one possible
way to interpret a sentence.
You can't just say that Romeo
and Juliet fell in love,
you must specify whether they
fell in love with each other
or individually with other people,
whether they just happen to
be in love while falling,
or whether they landed in a pile of love.
All the contextual clues and assumptions
that lubricate our everyday
conversations are forbidden.
This makes Loglan so difficult
that it's unlikely anyone
speaks it fluently enough
to actually test the Whorf hypothesis.
Making things even more complicated,
a disagreement between Brown
and his closest supporters
created a rift in the Loglan community
and a competing alternate
version called Lojban.
Disagreement is a common
theme in conlangs,
even Esperanto had its
schisms with offshoots
like Reformed Esperanto, Ido,
Mundolinco, and Romanico.
No matter how engineered a language is,
no matter how controlling its creator,
it will inevitably evolve
to fit the needs of the people who use it.
Like the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park,
language... finds a way.
Conlangs may not have a stellar
historical success rate,
but they do a great job
of revealing how we feel about language.
We can be entranced by its beauty,
fascinated by its variety,
but also frustrated with its limitations,
and even afraid of its
influence over our thoughts.
Perhaps there will never be
a truly universal artificial language,
but as long as people yearn
for new ways to express themselves,
they will always push the
boundaries of what language is.
We've only scratched the surface
of constructed languages,
there are over 500 of them
out there by one count.
If you wanna know more,
you could check out Arika Okrent's book,
"In The Land of Invented Languages."
(speaking in Klingon)
(whimsical music)
(Erica laughs)
(speaking in Klingon)